this is a big moment for the uk economy
because as well as having energy prices
uh increasing we've had that
confirmation from off gem as well as
having some intervention uh from the
government to try and deal with that we
also have news that the bank of england
well two things really the bank of
england has raised interest rates uh
from 0.25 to 0.5 percent it could have
been more four members of the monetary
policy committee were arguing for a half
uh point increase so they would have
gone up to 0.75 just to give you a sense
that they really are concerned about the
rise in inflation they forecast that
inflation is going to go above
seven percent this spring it's the
highest level since 1991 but here is the
most striking thing really when you look
within their latest forecast because
they've just released their latest
forecast for the state of the economy
when you look at all of these things put
together so the rise in energy prices
when you look at the rise in taxes the
tax burden very high at the moment when
you look at how weak earnings are
compared with inflation
you're seeing the biggest fall in
disposable incomes so you're talking
about post-tax labor income that's the
name of the series the biggest fall in
that series that we've ever seen as far
back as the records go they go to 1990
they are falling those labor income
disposable incomes they are falling by
two percent this year according to the
bank's forecast we've never seen
anything like that and it just
underlines what a cost of living crisis
we're facing at the moment the bank
talking about that talking about
inflation but saying that the risk of
higher inflation is so great that even
though this is going to cause more pain
for families particularly those on
floating rate mortgages not many people
but nonetheless some people they are
deciding nonetheless to raise
interest rates so a very big moment for
the uk economy uh given that just what
they're seeing out there uh the state of
the economy too and i should say i mean
normally in any other day this would be
a big story but they've also cut their
growth forecast by significant uh amount
as well so put it all together and it
really is a striking moment it really
feels like the moment that the cost of
living crisis has become
a living reality for many people for
millions of people around the uh the
country and the bank of england
underlining that we really haven't seen
anything like this for a long time